hi I'm Ryan Sumner and I'm with the IBM
cloud team today we're going to talk
about data transfer in and out of the
cloud data transfer means a lot to
different people but to me I focus on
the connectivity or the network
communication that occurs when
transferring data in and out of the
cloud really focus in on that I like to
use the metaphor of a road trip for a
road trip you you really you really
focus in on what you're gonna be taking
on your trip right where you're gonna go
how much stuff you're gonna need to take
with you you start to think about the
arrival time when you need to get there
the the route you're gonna take which
helps you define really the departure
time and then you know the risks and the
other kind of add-ons that you might
want during that trip how many stops you
might want to take and then you might
actually start reiterating over that
process as you're thinking about your
road trip
now we're communication and connectivity
is very similar to that you really start
to think about some of the risks
associated with the trip you're taking
because you're concerned about data
privacy right you start to think about
how much data you need to transfer right
so the size of that data you also start
to think about how long is it going to
take which helps understand how much
throughput or how much speed do I really
need to make this trip successful so as
we take this trip across the internet or
public trip we start down the road and
we hit these hops these are called
network hops each one of these hop hops
actually caused a change in the
direction of of our traffic because it's
an intersection point on the internet
for traffic to continue to go in another
direction or traffic to eventually get
to our destination that we're very
interested in so as we're going along we
actually have very little control over
how our data transfers from our
enterprise to the cloud if it's a
hundred
percent internet-based because there
might be outages somewhere across the
internet that we have no control over so
where we thought we might be going this
way we actually might get deferred in
this general direction which for our
case might actually be a faster trip but
back to the point you have very little
control over the way the data transfers
the quality of services we like to call
it in the industry is is fairly erratic
you have you know you can't create SL
a's around the quality of service across
the internet because a lot of those
things are outside of your control so a
lot of enterprises start to shift their
thought process into a private
connectivity pattern so if we fir that
back to our roadtrip analogy you you're
now really creating a dedicated
point-to-point connectivity or
point-to-point trip or road to get from
your enterprise to the cloud so again
where are some of these what are some of
the benefits here that we that we can
start to appreciate here if we think
about security right so so now I may not
necessarily need to encrypt my data
because now I have a private
communication between my enterprise and
the cloud and I don't have ease droppers
I have a little bit better control
around the quality of service because
I'm really dealing with myself a network
provider and my cloud provider to get me
from point A to point B I now have more
direct control over the number of hops
that I have to go through which will
affect my latency and will affect my
speed and so now I can actually dictate
and put specific controls over exactly
how much bandwidth or how large of a
road do I need to build between my
enterprise and the cloud so all these
things start to really make sense if you
really break it down and do simple math
and think about simple risks and tie
them back to my metaphor really you can
simplify the the challenges of data
transfer and network connectivity to the
cloud thank you if you have any
questions please drop us a line below if
you want to see more videos like this in
the future please like it and subscribe
and don't forget you can always get
started on the cloud at no cost by
signing up for a free IBM cloud account